[Music]
hello i'm christopher and we're at my
restaurant here at mihikeli tacoma
company and today i'm going to show you
how to make our kachita zepoyo aka slap
in the face grilled chicken and a
toasted tortilla melted cheese but today
we're gonna do with a twist of special
recipe that we do with my friend matt
kim and i so matt kim is one of my best
friends that we met a long time ago in
an empty parking lot when i started
selling tacos on the street he shows up
in his car i did not have a clue who
this kid is pops up his trunk pulls out
a cooler and all of a sudden he's like
the most popular kid on the block this
uni starts coming out i never seen uni
in my life and that's when i was
introduced to uni for the very first
time so we decided to put on everything
on the menu we put it on tacos and
quesadillas but my favorite by far was
the uni on top of our famous cachetta i
call it slap in the face because it's
spicy it's crunchy it is in your face
and it's amazing so to start off with
our cachetta
we are going to start off with our
all-natural corn tortillas we are going
to dehydrate those we're going to put
them on a plancha we're going to sit in
there for about five to 10 minutes we're
going to go on to our foyo asado and
we're going to start off with our
marinade first we have california chile
powder guajillo powdered onion powder
garlic powder cumin pepper salt and
sugar so now we're gonna go on with our
acidity so we're gonna do two portions
for something like this you need about
two oranges we need about one lime and
we're gonna give it a nice mix so the
acidity is very important because it
helps break down all the ingredients and
it also combines them together once it's
nice and smooth dunk in our chicken and
we're gonna give it a nice rub for
polyasolo in the restaurant we love to
use chicken thighs and chicken leg we
find that it's the juiciest part of the
chicken and it's the most flavorful of
all so we're gonna give it a nice mix a
minute or so make sure it's nice and
fully coated then we put it in the
fridge and let it rest there so while
that's resting and doing its magic we're
going to jump on to our pickled onions
time management is so important in the
kitchen so we're going to multitask a
little bit so we're going to take one
red onion cut it in half and give it
some nice fine julienne then we're going
to add our dried oregano make sure you
crush it very finely so what i like to
do with my oregano i like to grab a good
bunch and put it between my hands and
rub it very firmly so it turns into
powder and that's the best way for
oregano to do what it's supposed to do
we're gonna add a good amount of vinegar
you could use white vinegar red wine
vinegar apple cider vinegar whatever you
have at home season it with salt and
that's to give it a nice mix a nice rub
and again it goes into the fridge and
let it do its magic so food in my family
means everything it's the time that we
all get together forget it for mad at
each other celebrate things and it's all
good moments good happy memories it's a
way to remember our ancestors our
grandmas special recipes that are true
to our family mexicali it is actually
the place where i was raised and grew up
down in mexicali baja california i
learned a lot about hard work and
dedication i moved to la and i decided
that when i opened my first restaurant
or taco stand i was going to name it
after my hometown of mexicali baja
california and a lot of the influence
was this cuisine we showcased here at
the restaurant and i think it's proper
that we name it
one of the most important parts of our
cachita is actually our signature sauce
that goes inside chipotle aioli sauce it
sounds fancy but it's really just
mayonnaise with chipotle and a little
bit of seasoning we're gonna get our
mayonnaise we're gonna add a good amount
of chipotle sauce if you like it spicy
with a cake the way i do i would add
extra chipotle peppers in there we're
gonna add a little bit of salt sweeping
it out and we're gonna add a good amount
of lime juice give it a nice whisk so
it's nice and smooth and if you're like
me there's never enough heat put some
more of that chipotle on your ioli and
then again put it aside so our chicken's
been marinating about 15 to 20 minutes
we're gonna grab our chicken put it on
the grill you wanna go medium on this
one if you go too high you're gonna burn
the outside and the inside is not gonna
cook now it's very important when you're
grilling your chicken you gotta flip it
multiple times back and forth look for
those beautiful grill marks you know for
the smoke signals for the fire bursting
everywhere on the grill it's not like a
steak steaky let it sit there high heat
flip it once maybe and then it's ready
to go chicken you have to really
dedicate some time and give it some care
and you just want to get that nice char
oh that looks so good so now the chicken
is grilling matt is going to do his
thing he's so excited this is what he
lives for so he's going to crack it open
he's got this really cool device that he
uses and he's going to scoop out the
golden uni so he takes the uni he sits
it in water to rinse it off a little bit
and then it's ready to go what's so cool
about matt is that he's just as suspense
race as i am this guy will go rock
climbing scuba diving spear fishing all
the things that i love to do but i don't
really have the guts to so i kind of put
him to the test first he gets it done
then i say okay it's doable let's jump
on it we have an amazing relationship we
know each other very very well
especially when it comes to food so
we're always eating out and hanging out
and reminiscing and doing new adventures
all the time so now everything's coming
together we are getting very close to
the end we're gonna grab our chicken
take it off the heat and we're gonna let
it rest just as you would escape set it
aside for five to ten minutes while
that's doing its thing we're gonna grab
our tostadas nice and dehydrated crispy
but we're not done yet we're gonna load
it up with monterey jack cheese we're
gonna put them on the grill and we're
looking for those beautiful gooey cheesy
bubbly signs of cheese heaven our cheese
is doing its magical gooeyness we're
gonna go onto our chicken it's been
rested we're gonna slice it into cubes i
would say half an inch both ways i like
to cut it in perfect cubes it's for
presentation it's for a really good bite
so now it's time to put this all
together so we're going to load our
tostada with chicken so each bite is as
perfect as the first so now we're going
to go on and dress our cachetta with our
delicious aioli sauce and now it's time
to customize it this is where the
mexicali style comes in we're known for
customization every pallet is different
so finally now it's time to enjoy this
with my friend matt what are you gonna
put on it
the usual everything i personally like
to have some chili herbal it's spicy
it's smoky i like to put some aguacate
some avocado sauce and i like to put a
little bit of cabbage for a bite for a
nice texture and then we're going to add
some pickled red onions these are my
absolute favorite i put them on
everything and then this is where matt
kim comes in and he's going to show off
his skills with our golden uni and if
you're going to go with uni might as
well go all out you got to make it rain
and matt does that very very well so
we're going to load it up with uni just
how we like it brings back so much
memories this is the start of our
friendship salute cheers
each bite is like ocean meets mexicali
streets each memories fun times with
matt and i ah it is my favorite thing to
eat the uni the ocean i mean it's your
story with my story put together on a
bike dude this is perfect this is us man
right here so we are all done i hope you
guys love the cachitas as much as i do
try it at home it really is a slap in
the face
oh yes
nice there you go
[Music]